hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game that
took place yesterday in the melt weather
champions chester and
we said that we were going to discuss a
little bit about what this whole thing
is
so basically it's the fourth event of
the meltwater champions chester and
the second major one uh the first we
have the three days of the preliminaries
and then we go into the knockout phase
as we usually do we have 16 players who
are competing then
some of them will be eliminated before
the knockout phase and
the price fund is 220 thousand dollars
uh with uh sixty thousand dollars going
for for first place and the time control
we do know that this is rapid but it's a
15 minutes
for all moves with a 10 second increment
uh per move
starting with move one so here we have a
very nice game between daniel dubov and
the yanni pomnishi
and uh like i said i think even in the
previous video when the two of them
played
uh both of them are extremely extremely
exciting uh chess players uh
they play really really fun chess and
when the two of them play against each
other then there's always madness on the
board
uh so definitely we're going to cover
that and i did get a lot of your
suggestions regarding what other games
to cover i don't know
i will not be able to cover all of them
but i will cover at least
one one maybe even one and a half uh
before the start of of day two
so without further ado let's check it
out as do both opens with
e4 it's already on the board we have g6
by nipple going for the modern defense
or the so-called robot
with d4 and now bishop to g7 we have
knight to c3
and now d6 uh so just uh preparing to
develop the knight the bishop and so on
and grab the center with e5 at some
point
we have f4 now with further control of
the center
grabbing a lot of space here as you can
see and now knight to f6
nepo is now ready to castle we have
knight to f3 and castles
we have bishop to d3 so this has all
been played before
uh and now usually uh the the main stuff
here is knight to a6 and knight
to c6 but nepo goes for bishop to g4 and
while it's a very nice developing move
with the bishop
uh white will force a trade of uh bishop
for knight here with h3 this is what do
both plays we have traits uh we have
captures captures and
now e5 finally striking in the center as
dubose king still occupies the d1 square
so the captures we have d captures and
now just f5
advancing that pawn with knight to c6
uh and here bishop to e3
and it's interesting there's only one
game in the database that reached
this exact same position it was a from
the world
chess championship but world under 12
championship from the year 2000 the game
ended the draw between gonda and berkich
and the game continued in the exact same
fashion as this one here
so uh knight to d4 attacking the queen
uh you could capture the knight here but
that doesn't really uh give you anything
so queen back to f2 you want to keep the
pressure
and now uh nepo starts attacking with b5
so
uh it looks like a pawn sacrifice but
not really because this knight is needed
to guard the de4 pawn and you even
though you're attacking it twice then
you you don't want to allow something
like this
so here dubois ignores the pawn he just
castles and now he invites an airport to
attack the knight with b4 which he does
uh we have knight to e2 and now comes c5
so really cementing that knight on d4
with knights to g3
uh and now comes queen to c7 and this is
the new move the game that we mentioned
that took place in in
the year 2000 that continued with queen
to a5 here we have queen to c7
and it is only as of move 15 that we
have a completely new game
uh so let's see how uh duo will continue
this we have bishop the c4 it makes
sense to put pressure here on this
diagonal the queen and rook
also are ready to attack the fs df7 pawn
f captures and g6 is bound to happen at
some point so
queen to c6 by nipple adding another
defender to the knight here and also
putting more pressure to the to the pawn
here as the knight and the queen are
attacking it
but now there's simply uh well a very
good move for daniel here daniel here
plays f captures on g6 and now the
problem is you cannot go for knight
captures because this pawn is attacked
too many times g captures on f7 with
check and once you move the king now you
just trade here captures captures
and it's a completely winning position
for white just bishop d3 and that's it
the queen cannot remain on this diagonal
you don't have any squares here
you have to move the queen somewhere and
then you play queen h4 and there's
really no
no no defense against uh uh checkmate
here whatever you do
you're getting crushed so instead after
f captures and g6 with h captures and g6
and now
bishop to g5 another very strong move uh
threatening to win a piece here
so knights the h7 attacking the bishop
and now comes
bishop uh bishop to e7
uh you could also play bishop captures
an f7 with check and it's fine but it's
a rapid game you don't want to
allow something like king to h8 and then
you constantly have to worry about this
so instead after knight to h7 with
bishop to e7
makes sense of course you want to remove
the defender of the f7 pawn so
while that's not possible uh daniel will
definitely win
uh uh win the exchange on f8 so here
bishop the h6
uh preparing to block the queen's uh
attack to the f7 square with bishop to
f4 but also you have to be a little bit
careful
uh if this bishop ever got to e3
defended then you would have big
problems here
so rook a to d1 daniel says not a
problem here and now
bishop to f4 now the queen and rook no
longer have access to the f7 square so
now it's time to grab material bishop
captures on f8
rook captures on f8 and now knight to e2
now europe material now you have to go
for further trades we have knight
captures on e2 with
check queen captures and now knight to
g5 and it's looking looking very scary
but daniel finds a very nice
way to continue bishop to d5 uh chasing
back the queen we have queen to c8
and now h4 so what do you do here the
knight has to go back
knight's the e6 and now c3
so here we have king to g7 preparing to
shift the rook also to help out with the
attack
queen to f3 now uh we have b captures
b captures and then now f5 so again what
what do you play here uh we have bishop
back to c4 now opening up the d
file for the rooks the rook is coming to
d6 then you can double rook
rooks on the d file and this is what
daniel is going for we have rook to f6
adding a defender already to the sixth
rank and now
g3 uh pushing the bishop back we have
bishop to h6 and now
e captures on f5 we have g captures on
f5
and now rook to d6 so getting the rook
to the
to the sixth rank as planned and now e4
so here uh nepo is still down the
exchange but he does have a very strong
past
e pawn and uh dubo will have to uh be be
very careful
so queen back to d1 hoping to get some
some checks
over over this this way but now bishop
to e3 with
check king to h2 and here uh it's not
an easy uh position for for black to
continue playing this because
although black's pieces are very active
you do have a very strong pass pawn here
you just don't have a good way of
continuing the attack
so here nepal played something very very
in his style he played
knight to d4 he offers a piece here
but he's gonna get a massive center uh
because now okay the rook is under
attack you have to react to this
do of trades once we rook captures king
captures and he accepts the challenge c
captures on d4 uh we have c captures on
d4
and now uh white is uh
up uh material but the problem is black
has
these uh all of these pawns and if you
if those pawns start marching down the
board
uh it's gonna be very hard for white to
stop this so here while you could play a
move
your bishop is under attack you could
play something like bishop to b3 but
then you give black the initiative
and you have to consider everything what
if this pawn starts marching down the
border what if f4 happens you're going
to have to
weaken your king's position so not an
easy decision so instead
we have bishop to h5 saying you can have
your piece back
i'm just gonna go for uh this f5 pawn
and hopefully
we can deliver a nice checkmate here so
nepal doesn't have anything better
he decides to grab the bishop we have
queen captures on c4
and now rook captures on f5 with check
king e7 and now queen to h7 with check
we have king to d6
uh and now comes queen to g6 with check
we have king to e7
and now rook the e5 with check
and now there really isn't all that much
you can do here uh
if you don't go for this king to e7 uh
there's uh
i mean you could instead you could block
with queen to e6 but then this is
winning so
obviously you can't play that so here
after this check we have king to d7
and now comes queen to g7 with check we
have king to d8
and here uh daniel played the queen to
e7 check and it was in this position
that yanipon
should resign the game as there is
nothing more to be done
there is only one square for the black
king that is the c8 square and then of
course you get queen
rook to c5 check but also a lot of auto
moves are winning
uh so that's that's just it here this
would be completely hopeless
uh so after this uh queen to e7 check
and yep the
resigned and another wonderful victory
for daniel lubov uh and uh hope you guys
really enjoyed this because like i said
when the two of them play it's always
very very impressive stuff
uh so i'm not going to be able to cover
all of the games obviously
but i will cover at least one more game
and there also is
one very important position i want to
show you which will also
be probably in the next video uh so stay
tuned for that it's coming in
very very quickly uh so uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it we're
gonna check out the standings after
i check out some of some of the other
games so i don't spoil it for you
uh but yeah i would like to thank peter
dang
corey talley uh bon cloud chess henry
alma
and scott meliss for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the melt water champions
chest or checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day